[Music]  we chose a life of lies now those lies  have returned haunt us do we have a  right hide from method she has a  grandson we've hidden it took more than  a quarter of a century he's been told  his father died in battle and his mother  and child birth one of which is true do  you ever wonder what he'd be like now  you look as if you've seen a ghost are  you all right you remind me of someone I  used to know secrets that she's not  telling find out what it is I mean it's  a moment sweetie I would fight dragons  if I thought I might have a chance of  winning your heart  supposing you should want to make it  happen I do want to make it happen you  will marry John Venice's let's run away  together  [Music]  [Music]  it seems I'm in possession of a secret  yes  [Music]  you  you